good evening boards are up in the city
of las vegas tonight and
elsewhere across the country as we get
closer to inauguration day
and there's chatter indicating violence
and many people are getting nervous
sasha loftus joining us now live just
outside the foley federal building
downtown with more tonight
sasha denise local officials say
they're ready in case things get out of
hand here at home
those we spoke with here in las vegas
say they think it's a good idea
to board up buildings like the fully
federal building
here in the city as the inauguration of
president-elect
joe biden inches closer
many are concerned we'll see scenes like
this
again politically charged riots in
washington d.c
and potentially here at home there's a
lot of division
there's a lot of dissident right now in
the nation the foley federal building
downtown was boarded up friday
as local officials prepare for possible
unrest
i think that's smart because people have
a way of overreacting
u.s marshal for the district of nevada
gary shofield
sent this statement saying in part we
are taking the needed steps to protect
the judiciary
as we prepare for the presidential
inauguration
the nevada national guard says it also
has a plan
to make sure everyone's safety is its
top priority
the governor has taken the safety of
this state as the number one priority
he i'm in his contact with his office
every single day
we have members who are prepared in the
event that something would happen here
but no matter what takes place next
wednesday las vegas say
they want to see unity as far as
vandalizing and hurting other people
they're just hurting
you and will always push for peace
instead of turmoil
peace is something that needs to be
promoted and people aren't promoting it
enough
no other word on any other buildings
here in las vegas taking those extra
precautions other than the federal
building here
now as for the nevada national guard
they did head to
washington d.c today a unit of our local
national guard to
help with security surrounding the
inauguration and governor siselek
tweeted earlier tonight that they did
arrive safely reporting live downtown
sasha loftis
8 news now